bonsoir bonsoir alors un os de tesla
qu'est ce qui est important à retenir
pour vous aujourd'hui de cela mais en
fait les constructeurs automobiles qui
se sont tous lancés dans des programmes
électriques récemment font tous face au
même problème
on a fourni par an pile on voit souvent
beaucoup plus vite à produire des
voitures et on attend après des
batteries et tesla décidé de prendre les
devants et de fabriquer lui même ses
batteries présentement on est en
association avec panasonic qui depuis
des années fabrique l'epide c'est
panasonic aussi qui fabrique les pays de
la nouvelle grande usine qui est au
nevada mais là on va sortir une pays qui
va être plus puissante moins coûteuse
parce que le rêve des landes mascles
c'est d'amener ses véhicules électriques
ont même prix que les véhicules à
essence est l'obstacle majeur en ce
moment c'est la pile wallon que si on
arrive à faire une pile qui coûte
beaucoup moins cher on va être capable
de ramener le prix total du véhicule
beaucoup plus près d'un véhicule à
essence tout en ayant une autonomie qui
vaille finale finalement très semblables
un plein de carburant
on parlait de production beaucoup plus
large à partir de 2022 construction
d'une usine en chine si je me trompe pas
oui enfin en deuxième phase de
construction en chine il l'a annoncé
dans sa conférence de presse tantôt et
dans la banlieue de berlin on est en
train de construire une usine en fait ce
qu'ils racontaient dans sa conférence de
presse c'est que plus on est près du
marché dans lequel on vend moins les
coûts de revient sont élevés donc c'est
une autre façon de baisser le prix des
véhicules en état après du marché ou en
vain donc en étant en asie en europe et
en amérique du nord parce qu'on va
construire une deuxième usine à austin
au texas
on va être capable de diminuer les coûts
et on va être capable d'être plus
compétitif et puis faute est aussi oui
et il faut juste en terminant que le
marché très compétitif parce que l'on va
arriver avec des piles à électrolyte
solide
hydro québec est un des premiers qui va
amener sur le marché avec mercedes benz
essor tesla le sait et veut pour ce
faire
damer le pion bord c'est intéressant si
vous aviez vous aviez raison de la
ajouté je vais vous emmener sur freud
les cinq modèles de véhicules qui seront
fabriqués qui sont annoncés 2025 à 2028
est ce que c'est important historique ça
aujourd'hui c'est important parce que le
canada trenet on a annoncé à travers le
monde plus de 300 milliards
d'investissements en véhicules
électriques d'ici cinq ans et pour le
moment le canada avait zéro dollar dans
tout çà et là on vient de mettre les
deux premiers milliards sur la table
alors c'est un port en avant mais si on
veut rester compétitif en tant que pays
producteur de véhicules
il faudra qu'il y ait d'autres annonces
en fait jerry dias aurait le travail de
convaincre ca est de convaincre gm
d'aller dans le même sens parce que
l'avenir est là tous les nouveaux
modèles qui arrive ou presque sur le
marché en ce moment son ou hybrides
branchables ou complètement électriques
et les usines qui vont fabriquer ses
véhicules là ça sur une pérennité à long
terme et leur faut transformer bien sur
les chaînes de production c'est ça les
investissements les milliards vont là je
pense qu'on ne fait pas que transformer
pour faire par exemple d'une propulsion
à une traction avant ont fait des
modèles électriques donc il doit y avoir
une partie qu'il y inclus les batteries
parce qu'on va fabriquer les batteries
sur place aussi et c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué et coûteux et le niveau de
sécurité parce qu'on travaille avec
l'électricité évidemment la sécurité
beaucoup plus élevé d'où le prix pour
mettre tout ça en branle
mais c'est une bonne nouvelle est ce que
le marché est prêt à accueillir là on
est là à vouloir fabriquer des véhicules
électriques moderniser les batteries le
marché est-il prêt le marché au canada
est intéressé ce n'est pas encore par
tous les états unis ont encore du chemin
à faire mais avec toutes les recherches
qui ont lieu en ce moment et toutes les
façons dont on va amener parce que il ya
toujours eu trois obstacles majeurs au
véhicule électrique
le prix l'autonomie le temps de recharge
le jour où on aura un véhicule au même
prix qu'un véhicule essence qui va se
recharger en 10 minutes et qui va coûter
2 mai
qui aura plus de problèmes d'autonomie
convoqua 6 7 8 9 100 km mais les gens
vont embarquer c'est clair il ya encore
des j'irai des obstacles mais on
travaille très fort du côté des
constructeurs des manufacturiers des
équipementiers pour réduire l'écart
quand les véhicules s acheter les
véhicules et les honneurs question est
ce que les gens vont embarquer dans le
f-150 électrique ford calcul que 10% de
ses acheteurs à ce moment de f150 soit
ça veut dire qu'on fabrique 850 1950
1950 par année en amérique du nord
calcul que 10% de ces gens là seront des
acheteurs de véhicules électriques donc
fait le calcul on serait probablement
entre 85 et 95 me lâche pas ce qui pour
un modèle électrique en ce moment est
très très bon le donc oui ça vaut la
peine et c'est surtout que ça réduit
l'empreinte écologique des constructeurs
voient là et il n'y a pas beaucoup de
méthodes de faire ça avec un pick up
c'est vrai benoit charette merci
beaucoup merci à lui